un joueur de cornemuse seul au bord des
célèbres falaises de douvres
les alliés avaient réussi à faire croire
à hitler que le débarquement s'organiser
ici
il n'est pas complètement seul ce solde
avant
de spitfire nous sommes ici dans le ciel
de londres
un survol de la capitale britannique
pour célébrer l'armistice avec le virus
trafalgar square était bien clairsemée
pour la minute de silence pas les mêmes
images qui lie à 75 ans à 00h01 ce sera
la fin des hostilités explique alors
houston turkcell l'un de ses biographes
c'est lui son successeur trois quarts de
siècle plus tard 100 m
we know çi c'est le poème d'un vétéran
que li bruce johnson
la reine elizabeth ii a enregistré un
message pour célébrer la paix comme
l'avait fait son père le même jour en
1945 à paris sous l'arc de triomphe une
couronne de fleurs et la flamme du
soldat inconnu raviver emmanuel macron a
aussi rendu hommage au héros français de
la résistance et de la libération
le général de gaulle qui a sa statue au
milieu des champs elysées en allemagne
le 8 mai est aussi devenu une date
réjouissante le pays commémore très peu
la capitulation en temps normal
aujourd'hui nous pouvons dire que c'est
un jour de gratitude dit le président
allemand avec la france l'allemagne
appelle à une solidarité internationale
infaillible en ces temps de combat
contre un autre jardin lieu de l'autre
côté de l'atlantique c'est une cérémonie
virtuel qui a eu lieu ici au canada
[Musique]
le couple présidentiel américain est
allé lui aussi rendre hommage aux héros
de la guerre ceux qui sont tombés ce qui
reste
staline lui voulait que la reddition
soit signé à berlin que les russes
occupent au ce sera fait le 9 mai au
matin donc avec 24 heures de retard que
les célébrations mais déjà des vétérans
ont été honorés et presque centenaire à
qui certains soldats n'hésite pas à
serrer les mains il si mathieu poste
radio canada montréal